[Music]
welcome back to cbs morning's earlier we
reported on text messages obtained by
cbs news and the washington post that
illustrate the extraordinary
relationship between the wife of a
supreme court justice and the trump
white house the text between justice
clarence thomas's wife her name is
virginia conservative activist who goes
by jenny and trump chief of staff mark
meadows document her attempts to help
guide president trump's strategy to
overturn the 2020 election cbs news
chief election and campaign
correspondent that's robert costa is
back with us along with bob woodward his
colleague at the washington post good
morning to you both we're normally got
two bobs but robert we're going to stick
with robert for you today so robert
start us off of these 29 texts is there
anything that stands out to you more
than others and do you believe that
there are other texts that we have not
seen yet
there might very well be texts we have
not seen 29 were provided to the
committee 21 from jenny thomas to
meadows eight from meadows to ginny
thomas these were part of a collection
of over 2 300 text messages meadows
provided to the committee but there are
gaps i mean the last text in what we've
reported comes in late november 2020
then there's a stray one about vice
president pence and the end of america
in january of 2021 days after the
insurrection so this is a story that's
beginning not ending why do you think he
would turn over checks that contain such
information that is so potentially
damaging to them
i i think there was a process where they
had a legal team looking through these
in the days after the election there was
a more cooperative atmosphere but uh
robert and i've been talking about what
not just the details of these text
messages but what does it mean and it
shows that jenny thomas was acting like
a political consultant a true believer
political consultant or campaign manager
advocating smearing
what in one text is called the biden
crime family who are
involved in
ballot fraud again there's nothing
to support that
but what
really struck me was
the
effort by jenny thomas and mark meadows
to
say they are taking the moral high
ground and here
you see
meadows saying this is a fight between
good and evil now
that's the problem with our politics now
everything is seen oh this is evil if
it's on the other side we are good
it's certainly this is an
i'm sorry go ahead
bob it's it's certainly uh us versus
them mentality in washington these days
but robert do you know
if justice thomas himself was aware of
these text messages at one point she
refers to i talked to my best friend we
don't know what that means but do you
think that he was aware of this
conversation
that's a question for the january 6
committee gail and the question i have
as a reporter and woodward and i have
discussed this is will this committee
now issue a subpoena for jenny thomas
will
perhaps even consider
asking the justice himself clarence
thomas to come in and talk to the
committee
this is a tricky area for congress that
the oversight of a supreme court justice
is always a bit of a vague area congress
can impeach a supreme court justice if
they wish but otherwise supreme court
justices have enormous independence
jenny thomas though is clearly
communicating a legal strategy a
messaging strategy political strategy
with the chief of staff of the white
house executive branch official
communicating with the spouse of a
judicial branch official and in these
text messages we also see discussion of
the legislative branch
a map of trump relationships and this
mission to overturn the election
stretching across the entire u.s
government
so bob it's vlad uh looking at what we
know so far about the investigation and
your reporting and the fact that there's
a recent court filing from the january 6
committee where lawyers in the panel say
they have a good faith basis for
concluding that former president trump
engaged in a criminal conspiracy where
else do you think that this might lead
well it's a question of getting more
information but
see the people who believe in the
constitution the constitution makes very
clear after an election for a president
is held the states submit their electors
and they did in this case and there is
this memo which we have in our book
peril by the constitutional scholar
john eastman really planning a coup
literally saying oh there's seven states
who submitted
alternative electors
zero evidence of that uh investigations
conducted by trump supporters and
it's the tone of
these texts that really struck me after
doing this for 50 years and that is
the discussion
in one of the last texts by jenny thomas
it's the end of america if we lose this
apocalyptic
language this idea that this isn't just
a political skirmish or fight this is a
moral one this is
uh
not
our
existence really hinges on doing it our
way well as the great
graham green the british novelist said
you've always got to understand that the
other side has a case
and
so what jenny thomas has done here what
mark meadows said they've just turned up
the heat and the division in the country
in a way
that uh leads us to the
let's be direct about it the political
catastrophe we are living through
now robert i want to get back to justice
thomas um we know that supreme court
justices are known to have political
leanings and if justice thomas is known
to be more conservative why does his
wife's activism in a conservative way
have an impact on what is going on
it's a good question but it's and it's
no surprise however that jenny thomas is
a political activist this has been
something she has done
most of her professional and adult life
she's been
on the right wing she's been part of
many groups that are advocating for
conservative causes and the justice and
his spouse have long maintained that
they have independent professional lives
and she has a course a first amendment
right to participate in political
activity and say whatever she would like
the question that now arises for the
january 6 committee is whether she had
any role in what they are now asserting
in a court filing was this criminal
conspiracy and what was the knowledge if
any of the justice of his wife's
activities and this
as bob and i have discussed it in recent
days an unprecedented entanglement
between a spouse close to the judicial
branch and a white house chief of staff
we're in uncharted territory with a lot
of this reporting and we're going to
have to just see where it goes and pull
the thread even more
all right robert costa and bob woodward
we like to say here at cbs news original
reporting and we'd like to say exquisite
storytelling bravo to the two of you
thank you very much more to come for
sure
jenny thomas and justice thomas did not
respond to our request for comment on
this story we reached out several times
jenny thomas has publicly denied that
any conflict of interest exists between
her marriage to a supreme court justice
and her work as an activist mark
meadow's lawyer has said the texts the
text exchanges rather do not present any
legal issues here to be continued for
sure that's for sure